hi guys I'm Greggy
I'm MacDonald Szechuan sauce so many
people have said Greg Greg you must
watch this video first one to request
this Samuel Royden Sammy Samuel
hemorrhoids watch the rack Iraq it
Ronald McDonald trailer
Oh God John why talk anymore and why
because I can't think of a logical
reason let's get into this let's hope
this goes bananas per rack of the racket
which initially turns your school life
we're approaching the one-year
anniversary
tell me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
doing
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Rakha the rack iraq inators wasn't that
bad in violent terms no they did get you
to get surprised no man i could change
that of a kid's face chains on child's
face and one of the best visual gags
that you have a long time know with the
YouTube algorithm in a restricted mode
and YouTube's pulling all their and I'm
losing all their advertisement this came
at the right time no yeah sure
McDonald's in case you're going to want
ever to not abused they're probably
getting how quickly did they make this I
don't know they make these they cook
these up pretty fast I think these guys
are harder crew yeah I my favorites just
inhaler kid so the wedding scheduled is
me their child is I think my favorite
moment it was smart it took bits of it
it took bits of like their playground
slaughter of the McDonald thing and then
the Ronald McDonald character included
in this yeah it's just reimagine that
trailer but instead of what if it was a
Ronald McDonald out yeah like Harlequin
clown it's their Ronald McDonald because
their Ronald McDonald is they like it
can be out of a horror movie that
character
he's very file yeah I a psychotic and
twisted so he is like their killer clown
character because their Ronald McDonald
ever not
something horrific I don't know oh and
the KFC bucket I thought that was a cool
atmosphere when they really go crazy at
the end of this when they just start
adding all their own stuff with like the
weird balloon room and the birthday
party with the KFC bucket on stuff like
I use geyser but this statue they have a
great there's a great cinematic look to
all this I thought this is one of their
better shot ones in terms of Jam visual
and the lighting I thought it'd look
really really good framing of it all
production values are great on this
thing man who are these kids they hired
I think I've seen them in other videos
before maybe they just have like a whole
talent agency of everything showing back
a little kids maybe they do we're young
parents and we're putting y'all to work
I like that bit of Pennywise running
yeah that's right
Ramadan would win in a fight against
anyone this Ronald McDonald oh yeah
because this problem we go would play
[ __ ] nasty remain an actual raw makan
little place ROM McDonald is the actual
Ronald McDonald like they actually guys
know gambling yes change engine was his
first major role was as a burger
slinging Clinton from the McDonald's
Corporation I think it should make an
actual movie out of this I just do yeah
I think I just make an actual movie Oh a
wrecker movies coming Iraq Iraq and
movies coming it's gonna be twisted it
can be darkest comedy anyone's ever see
it's going to be like a demented Rob
Zombie movies yeah I think it's going to
be like the most slapstick comedy circle
Rob Zombie your asses ever see just loud
Australians instead a subscribe to the
real rejects subscribe to Iraq Iraq a
while you're at it
this guy's reason to Jerry on the social
media social media manager of Blum house
and the real rejects yes shout out to
there's this reaction channel called
Deadpool party Deadpool party have like
he has like 60 thousand subs icesoft you
this guy's videos he's really funny I
think you guys should go over there and
watch him because he's a hilarious
hilarious [ __ ]
Deadpool party